my name is Carlo Giacometti in this talk
I will cover the new capabilities of the
wealth of language at the intersection
between neural networks and audio
processing
so my name is camel Giacometti and today
i will talk about never knife looks for
audio of mainly analysis I would say so
the first thing I want to show that is
has been updating 12 is the audio Navin
coil so any coders of the entry point
for data on to the world of neural
networks these do have introduced as I
said in last version 11 3 and they allow
very fast and parallel feature
extraction from all your both objects
and file files several different
features can be computed using net
encoders and I will very quickly go
through them one is just a plain wave
for the short time for it as firm can be
computed the spectrogram the mouse back
to Iran which is that similar object
with a more of human-friendly frequency
scale and the mouth frequency sets all
coefficients so this already existed in
11 3 it has just been made more
efficient and faster another thing that
has been added to the audio coder is
augmentation so if you have a limited
amount of data you really want to track
the network and believing they is seeing
a more varied distribution of data and
many times this kind of recommendation
needs to happen before the feature
extraction process and this is why we
have included it in the encoders one
example of argumentation that could
happen is shifting the time of the input
signal so and this can be randomized
according to an distribution that can be
specified by the user you can see here
the two different inputs have this
different stopping point and
can happen at a training time online
noise can be added to the input to make
the network more robust to different
kinds of signals so the noise can be
automatically computed as white noise
but you can also compute or generate a
noise signal in this case but if you
have a newer machine a collection of
noise samples that are representative of
the real-world data that your network
will see this is an extremely useful
augmentation for your network
convolution just convolved the signal
with some impulse response and simulates
the presence of different kinds of
reverberation so all of this is useful
to prepare the network to signals that
are not really in your tiny set to allow
the network to generalize better
different kinds of data does it really
help is it really useful so here I have
the spoken digits commands data set
there has a collection of digits spoken
by various people and what I have done
here is training the same network same
parameters the only difference is that
one encoder has no augmentation and the
other one adds noise randomly to the
input and as I said they I am limited
the amount of data that I'm exposing to
the network and both trainings whoops
both trainings succeed and converge and
you can compare the two results one one
standard measure is the accuracy and you
can see that even in this very much toy
example we get a two percent absolute
boost on the accuracy of the result
kurz is really very much depends on the
kind of problem that you're trying to
solve but this is definitely a very
valuable addition to our framework in
other words new thing in version 12 it's
already identified what does it do it
takes a signal this case is this one not
as annoying as the previous one and it
tries to figure out what are the
contents of it
you can specify you can restrict the
search on a limited set of categories
you can return multiple results you can
return the probability well the score of
those results and of course everything
here is based on a neural network that
users can access using the net model at
the moment it is hidden in our
repository but we are planning to make
it public when we have a final version
this though is accessible by anyone it
just says hidden in the name but it is
definitely accessible so we did the
training of this network in-house how
does it work
what was it trained on we use the audio
set which is a data set that was
released by Google that contains a
couple of millions of audio snippets
that are labeled with a collection of
632 all event classes these are some
examples of classes you can see human
sounds voice exit etc these classes can
be represented with sound entities in
the vault on language and you can even
gather a description out of them now
these classes are organized in an
ontology so there are some hierarchical
relationships between the various
classes that can be accessed with this
nice private function
as you can see it is a messy graph it is
it is a messy gun
it has some issues as you can see some
of the classes have multiple parents
which leads to problems in scoring the
results but this is how the the data set
was released and this is what we have
used one very important characteristic
of the data is that it is it is
inherently multi-label so for one single
sound it that can be assigned multiple
labels so for example there is in the
song or in their recording their second
term but there's also a person speaking
or an electric piano or something both
of those labels are present in the
training set so we are not doing a
classification where the classes are
mutually exclusive
it is a multi-label classification which
is a very different problem as you can
see this is one example of the training
data and these refer to the audio files
and these are some representation of
three classes so this this segment
contains all of these three classes so
how does the training work in this weird
multi-label selling we what ends up
happening is that you need a separate
classifier for each class and this is
done by specifying that at the end of
the classification layer the the
non-linearity used is logistic sigmoid
applied independently to each of the
inputs rather than a soft month layer
with which would present the mutually
exclusive probability case and then of
course the result of these independent
classifiers is passed to a cross entropy
loss that is then averaged over all the
classes so this is how the data was
structured what
is the network well we can inspect it
very easily well this looks very long
the architecture is called mobile
network - the inspiration for the
protection was taken by this paper but
we are not using a more modern
architecture this is mobile not version
2 is a convolutional neural network that
is generally used for image processing
now image processing Network the input
is of a fixed sized audio is inherently
valuable size so how do we connect these
two worlds well we connect this to earth
by massaging the output of our encoder
so we can extract our encoder and see
what it does as you can see the crucial
operation here after ml spectrogram is
extracted so you have a variable length
matrix this variable length matrix is
then partition on a sequence of fixed
dimension intervals this way we can map
the fixed length neural network onto
each of these chunks and let's see so
this is the result of the encoder as I
said we can use net map operator to
apply the net on to every single every
single one of these chunks and this
gives us in this case this result we in
this case the number of chunks that we
have extracted is 2 so we get two
classifications but we really want to
have one single output that audio signal
so we need to aggregate along the
time-dimension
we cannot really use the average since
we don't want to know what the average
sound was we really want to know what is
what sounds were played so we use an
aggregation layer where the aggregation
function is max so this way we collapse
the time dimension and get a single
result this is result and once we have
this resolved we pass this to the
decoder of the
knows about which classes are in the
training beta and thus can give us a
series of probabilities so this is the
or network in order identified we take
housing into consideration information
from the ontology two squares old again
this is the big messy graph from the
ontology and we can formally identify we
can control how much information on the
ontology is used to score the result by
the specificity go option in this case
we can give more or less weight to
elements that are closer to the branches
of this graph adapted rather than the
center and you can see the generality of
the result here I am marking all the
values from 0 to 1 and you can see the
first result is acoustic guitar the
result from specificity all goes to one
is just music so it also it's also
possible to run it in the real time
dynamically in this case I have this I
just made quickly this on the object
earned by joining all of our audio data
I am creating an audio stream and
playing it and now I will run or didn't
find real time on the signal from this
stream and it could be also a stream on
the microphone and we have some demos in
there in the basement that where you can
experiment with this if you if you are
so inclined so this is this is all you
identify now sure figuring out what
instruments or what sound steps is
having an audio signal is interesting
but it doesn't have many superb
education but one important thing that
we can get out of this training network
is semantically significant feature
extractor
extraction so what we can do is chop off
the last few layers of the network that
are in charge of the classification this
is what I'm doing here what this
produces is oh okay there's some issue
here with this produces is a fixed
length vector that is semantically
meaningful with respect to the content
of the audio signal so here I am
collecting all of our example data and
then I am trying to do feature space
plot of our example data by specifying
that the feature extractor to be used is
the network that we just produce and you
can see that there is so these are all
the values of the object you can see the
spectrum but you can also we will return
later you can see that similar signals
[Music]
are clustered together and yes so this
is a more concrete application for the
network how do you find out if two
signals are semantically signals
semantically similar this is one way you
compute features from them and you
compare the features in their feature
space and by the way now we have
included the network that we are using
as a default feature extractor for all
of their machine learning functionality
say efficient extract feature space
block classify product so now if you do
feature space plot of a list of all the
objects that network is automatically
used and as you can see you still get
semantic separation of clusters now
another use of the network it can be
used as a starting point for doing more
specific problems the one that I'm
showcasing here is it's very simple we
have a deficit that is called IR mas the
contains a collection of audio snippets
of values instruments and the
instruments are labeled so let's see
this file for example contains organ and
etc etc or a flute there are only 11
available classes but if you had to
kinda know scratch to distinguish from
all of these classes that would be a
fairly resource intensive process and
probably would get a reasonably bad
result because the amount of data is
fairly limited it's I think only a few
thousand examples compared for example
to a data set that we use for all the
identify which is a couple of million of
examples so we are kind of cheating the
system and using the feature extraction
from the audio identify net as a
stopping point for this classification
so the problem is not anymore to
classify an audio object into eleven
classes but the problem is I want to
classify a vector of length about 1,000
into 11 classes which is much more
manageable so here I am using just
classify and I have pre encoded the data
just for your purposes I will not run
the computation it takes about three
minutes but I don't have that much time
so and then you can easily look at the
classify of measurements of the result
and you can see with limited data live
at a time very limited services I still
get a 91% accuracy on the data set now
this was the
kind of lazy approach we left classify
to do all the work but we can start from
the same starting point the exact
features and train there's more neural
network is more classifier neural
network from scratch and as you can see
the net is essentially two linear layers
with the respective nonlinearities and
that's it and as an input it gets the
yes yes so as I said a few classifier
layers and that's it and we can see how
long it actually takes to drain let's
see what good
oh I think there is some issue actually
yes that's not look promising okay I
will use the pre-computer Rizal just let
me check everything yes that is
definitely not giving me this okay
so evidently I use some slightly
different hyper parameters earlier I'm
not getting the same result but with a
very tiny fully connected network of
just in this case three layers I can get
a 95 percent accuracy on as I said our
very limited in the reserves deficit and
with this we can create by joining the
network that we use that Fischer X staff
with the network that we just drained we
can create a full net that takes and all
the object as an input extract the
feature and I classifies it and let's
grab the random example from the
instrument down set and this does the
classification from all the object to in
this case one of eleven instrument
classes it it just works and this is the
magic of transfer learning you use the
network that was pretty trained for a
similar but different but not the exact
same task and you retrain the last few
layers that are in charge of the
classification that this reduces greatly
the resources needed to be successful at
that kind of project in other
new function that was introduced in 12
is speech recognizer so there are
several the goal of the function is to
figure out what the picture of a
monophonic signal is and by monophonic I
mean only one service was playing at a
time so in this case I will have a piano
signal let me play that with you
[Music]
so of course there are very valid
classic signal processing algorithms and
there can be applied to this that do not
use machine learning at all that is the
default method used in pitch recognized
but if you want more precision at the
cost of definitely longer evaluation
time you can use a different method in
the function that calls a neural network
and now and this is nice the interesting
thing is that the backend of this
function is network that is present in
the neural net vote from neural net
repository and it's called creep here we
go
this network acts on there all way from
of the signal that is then partitioned
and classifies that signal onto a a
collection of one of three hundred sixty
pitch classes so these are pitch classes
is not a frequency we need to transform
it to a frequency
there are several choices that range
from a simple interpolation to using a
hidden markov process to have a cleaner
decoding so we can compute the result of
the network and it will take a little
bit of time is as I said it and and this
really depends on your machine
if you are able to evaluate this in a
machine with a compatible GPU there will
be of course much faster we can use the
hidden markov process to decode there
the result and this whole process gives
us both the prediction of the pitch but
also gives us a production of their
confidence of our resolve and we can
visualize this result here the color the
opacity of of the line in this plot is
elated to the confidence of our solve
and this is how they know
to backhand or pitch recognize works
thank you very much this is the team
that works on signal processing and
thank you again
[Applause]